perfidia roles show back to the 80s
something that we've all forgotten about
how to make the perfect choux pastry
first and foremost important turn the
oven on 125 mils of milk 200 mils of
water in to the pan it's important that
we bring it to the boil slowly butter
caster sugar salt it stops it from
becoming over sweet and gives a really
nice sort of rustic flavor to it off the
heat 150 grams of plain flour vigorously
fold that flour in back onto the heat
like that look beautiful just hanging
off the spoon cool eggs really
importantly put the eggs in one at a
time therefore you get this really nice
incorporation of the white and the yolk
look beautiful
hiding bag one nice lump and look just
coming through there she is there
three smooth paper starting from
sticking to the tray down push and
pissed away perfect
now finger into a bottle of water and
just push down those little pointed bars
this stops it all from burning into the
oven 18 to 20 minutes chocolate sauce we
use between sort of 60 and 70 percent
pure carry the better the chocolate the
better the source simple as there and
the secret now is to melt this chocolate
overall can of simmering water that will
melt within three to four minutes butter
honey just look now that's beautiful
smooth and just this wonderful texture
there take it off the heat and that man
was perfect milk
out
creme Chantilly basically a really nice
flavored cream icing sugar vanilla
and then mix it
nice piping bag
push in for the role generously fill up
to see the Queen bouncing back at you
and just sticking together
lovely icing sugar
chocolate sauce into a junk
I've hit the road with chocolate sauce
and Chantilly cream done slightly tilt a
knife down one at the top and then
gripping the onion like a tennis ball
holding it together in play